qui fait un peu de magie à part maximale
au nom et ses seuls non personne n'à ban
on est désolé à tous les talents bon
mach si vous avez un petit tour avec
vous j'ai toujours un petit tour sur la
main alors j'ai demandé quelques cordes
à notre ami à magali berda les clubs
pour nous est lâché un peu les poignets
sauf que là on va essayer de faire une
expérience un peu particulière avec ses
décors vous savez on les place de cette
manière et regarder ce qui se passe
normalement si je souffre là je souffle
ils gagnent fusion qui infuse ion entre
deux corps à l'intérieur
doucement mais sûrement à l'intérieur
comme ça croyez le ou non
la magie est effectué
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas un petit tour sur vous
même parce que la lavalloise à leroy il
explosé de rire vous avez que ça vous
c'est vrai les moringueurs le 28 le 28
décembre c'est vendredi prochain
c'est la plus haute distinction du monde
de la magie de la prestidigitation
c'est un spectacle familial à on
récompense évidemment les magiciens mais
surtout c'est un spectacle où il ya de
la grande illusion ou l'ia du close up
de la magie comique arturo a reçu à mon
trac d'honneur et là on reçoit les les
stars de la manche du mondial
penn and teller qui ont leur show à las
vegas hollywood sur leur étoile sur le
hollywood walk of fame
c'est juste incroyable bon comme la
finlande de voir toutes les boyaux qui
sort son maximum il est beau gosse en
grève quand l'image figée
gc oui alors à propos de maxime j'ai vu
j'ai enquêté sur de présenter et j'ai eu
le producteur gilles arthur qui m'a dit
ou textos maxime gainey et la fusion de
sabatier et de foucauld aux adc
l'animateur de demain
[Applaudissements]